let's start with maria this hour in
chicago hi maria
welcome to the ramsey show hi dave very
excited to talk to you thank you so much
sure my question my question is this
it's going to be
uh well i guess i'll ask the question
first and then i'll give you the
background
okay is it financial is it friendly just
financially speaking not
not regarding how i feel about home
ownership just financially speaking
i'm 58 years old i i have no debt
i have fully funded emergency fund i
have fully funded retirement both roth
and 401k
how much i own my how much is in it
there's about a million in it
okay good for you well done between the
between the both i raised my four kids
they're all out of college
um i'm single and i my house home's
worth about 350
and i paid it off it's paid off okay
taxes are really high
taxes are really high in illinois
okay but anyway so i i think i want to
downsize because i don't need my house
anymore
cool and i'm not i i so i would go to
like a townhouse
okay so just financially just
financially speaking
it would it be a really bad idea for the
next 30 years for me just to rent
and the reason why i asked that is
because in my heart i've had so much
responsibility in my whole life raising
my four kids keeping up with my house
i wouldn't mind just writing a check
every month and just be done
and uh finally but everybody's telling
me like financially speaking
you could sell your house to 350. go buy
something for 250 or less
i'm like but then i thought you know
then i gotta worry about the house again
the windows the roofs the gutters that
all that you know
[Music]
the question no yeah it makes a lot of
sense i understand
so uh did you raise your kids by
yourself or your single mom
for the most part i mean i was divorced
and they were very very young he was he
was
so for 20 years for 20 years you've been
a she-bear out here fighting
scratching clawing and you've cleaned
the gutters you've done whatever it took
and you're just tired
yes i worked overtime every month at
work sure i was
yeah i thought you were there in time i
thought you were that girl you sound
like that girl
you sound like a warrior a warrior
princess
um so uh
well let's first answer your question
then let's try to look for a solution
okay
the problem with your the good part
about your theory is you don't have to
screw with stuff because the landlord
does
so you get all this stuff out of your
life the bad part about this is
think about what rents have done in the
last 30 years
and think about what they're going to do
during the 30 years that we're talking
so if you rent instead of owning a paid
for
property going into retirement you're
destabilizing your life because
every year your housing cost is going to
go up
true so that's why it's a bad plan
it's not a bad plan to rent for a short
period of time while you're rearranging
things or you're in a transitionary
stage or something like that
but renting for 30 years means you are a
victim of the real estate market instead
of
riding the wave can i throw something
else at you
yep okay so i put down on paper because
this has been like uh
stressing me out so i put down on paper
my taxes
versus all my bills in my house i think
you need to move
okay but like i i even projected class
if i was in the townhouse
yeah here's what here's what i want you
to here's what i would do if you're my
little sister
and you're old enough to be my little
sister okay
not your older sister no i'm 60. so i
got you beat
but the uh uh but so uh i would tell you
you don't want to work on crap and you
don't want crap breaking and you are a
millionaire
so you need to go a buy a brand new
condominium where someone does all the
exterior maintenance and every
appliance and everything inside is brand
freaking new
you earned it you're a rock star and you
need to enjoy a little bit of this money
and it's like buying a really nice car
that's in really good shape after you've
been driving a freaking beater
and it breaks down all the time and you
know my cars don't break down
now back when i had crap cars
because i was trying to get here they
broke down all the time
but you're a warrior girl and you need
to you need to enjoy the spoils
of the battles that you have won and
that's a million dollars in a 350 000
paid for house
you're worth a million and a half
dollars i want you to sell this house i
want you to buy 350
000 condo you may want to move
uh to an area that is that probably
it might feel a little bit oh like it's
a little too richie rich for you but you
need to live there anyway
wow okay i'll think about this thank you
very good information
what do you think john yeah i think that
transition when you
it's when you're a single mom when
you're raising kids and you're putting
them through college and you're saving
you're working you're doing overtime
it's kind of like being gazelle intense
for 20 30 years
and suddenly your uh your identity is
i'm a sprinter i'm a fighter that's what
i do
yeah and how do you settle back down you
could hear like man for someone who's
accomplished what she's accomplished the
fact that this decision is keeping her
up means it's not about this decision
it's about i've got to shift gears and
become something else right
that's a big big transition yeah what do
you do when you come home
from a 20-year campaign
on the road with alexander the great and
you're one of his soldiers after 20
years how do you stop
fighting and scratching you will pick
from your neighbors with your dog how do
you stop it you know and so
you know and that's what she is she's a
warrior princess that's right and so
you know she's been these single moms
man they they get her done
these are some of the toughest people in
on our planet
and um so yeah that that that's uh uh
and that's who she is and and she's like
i i you know she's kind of telling
herself good
things like i deserve a rest that's
right and dave
we talk a lot about people making
decisions out of stress or out of
um anxiousness that's very similar to
making
decisions out of exhaustion i'm just i'm
done i'm out
right i just want to i know the math is
bad i know it's going to destabilize me
20 years from now
i'm exhausted i
i've talked to people who get divorced
because i'm just tired of it
right so i love your i love your idea of
man right now it feels good it's not
going to be good down the road no it's a
bad long term plan
yeah i would buy something brand and
investigate the builder and make sure
it's an incredibly
high-end high-quality builder
so you are living in a luxury situation
in terms of the service you're going to
be provided as well as the goods love it
you've earned it you're a millionaire
way to go